I would like to say
a massive thank you to all the
supporters we have around the world
regardless of what the mainstream media
keeps saying and the lives they try and
purport we get tens of thousands of
messages from people
you're all very interested in me as you
can see
ridiculous humiliating ludicrous
Virginia Jury has found that Amber Heard
defamed her ex-husband Johnny Depp in
Brazil have charged a woman who accused
the international footballer Neymar with
raping her we learned today that a
federal judge in Nevada has thrown out a
rape lawsuit against soccer Superstar
Cristiano Ronaldo fake news the guy
asked the question saying how come you
didn't do any police report back then as
well because it's not fully rape and
it's not bad because it was consensual I
kind of wanted to be there and I didn't
tell anybody about it six years later
there's way too many things that doesn't
give it credibility for somebody to say
I didn't do anything about it then but
six years later I told my friends three
or six years later yeah and this is the
thing that's scary if you say to any
red-blooded male 13 years ago you had
sex with a woman consensually and she's
now unhappy about how that sex happened
you can get any man on Earth can get
screwed with that if this person exists
at all and like you said she refused to
go to the police if she exists and she's
saying it was consensual I think last
night they aired it on news night and
she literally they said why are you
coming forward now and I think she this
actor the person literally said because
now he's rich and famous they literally
said those words and as I said there's
all that evidence showing that you know
the main complaints were conspiring to
lie yet they're still you know
restricted and not able to move out of
their homes so
I I I want to believe in in the legal
system but wow why is it taking so long
you know it is a concern in that sense I
don't know if you know Amir Junaid
formerly known as uh loon I was alone
and all of the songs that I'm doing is
female oriented you know female driven I
needed yeah I wrote all these records if
the truth is and as long as my witness
that you know this as well being in the
business we used to be in living the
lifestyle we used to live we encountered
so many people we shake so many hands we
introduce people all the time
yeah so my only involvement was a simple
introduction to two individuals who went
on to do things that had nothing to do
with me you kind of look a little bit
different to me today than how we've
been seeing you in those pop videos is
Lewin still in there somewhere Lauren is
uh working his way out of my system from
Bad Boy Records he he was with Puff
Daddy okay he had something similar we
were I was talking to him the other day
he'd like to actually uh talk with um
with Andrew because he had a similar
situation he was a very famous hip-hop
artist you can look him up and he
accepted Islam and then shortly after he
accepts Islam he gets hits on some
conspiracy charge he didn't even do the
crime but he was now years ago something
came up and then boom they locked them
up in 2008 with a group of individuals
who I only knew one person
and this is prior to Islam I wasn't a
Muslim yet so this was me at the very
you know weaning stages of leaving the
music business
my love for the underdog I met a guy who
was you know inspiring to be an artist
and I tried to show him a way
through the means and resources that I
had
so
in my bad judgment he inquired about
something
that at the time you know I'm saying I
was knowledgeable of but I wasn't
involved in
so I actually did something that became
detrimental later is I introduced him to
somebody who they had a relationship in
the conspiracy revolved around their
relationship and their dealings I was
free from the matter so now fast forward
I become Muslim
and like I said I fled with my religion
everything I did was public so it wasn't
like I was a fugitive I was running from
anything every talk I gave including
your show everything was transparent
everything was visible and obtainable
now when I get to Belgium I'm told by
Interpol I got grabbed by Interpol I was
told that I had an indictment in the
eastern district of North Carolina in a
city called Durham which I never visited
so now this is already a fishy situation
but fighting to make sure my extradition
was not violated on my constitutional
rights wasn't violated I came to you
know
Stateside and I was sentenced to 14
years in prison you know for conspiracy
to possess when intent to distribute a
kilo I had run I never sold everyone a
day in my life with lion and
the individuals who put me in the
conspiracy I didn't have any real
feelings with these guys you know so so
you introduce introduce a to B
pretty much and and I became cdef all
the way to Z yeah simple
so
that's interesting when you when you
look at
um we know in Islam that a person can go
towards an evil deed right and then if
they might have an intention but even if
they don't do the evil deed they get the
reward they get the reward right
um or you know they thought about doing
something they were about to do it again
they walked away but here you didn't
even do it yeah right you you introduced
two people absolutely whatever they did
and then how do you end up going to see
the one thing I've never done through
the course of my whole incarceration is
try to figure out the wisdom behind what
Allah had to create yeah you know and
that's something that can definitely
lead to removing yourself yeah from
understanding what is clear as far as
where the law established of accepting
his Divine to create the good event and
the bad of it so the tangible evidence
is what people struggle with yeah but
the ultimate defining factor is that
this is from a large decree so so I
accepted it and for nine years I was
able to increase in everything I was
searching for prior to that because you
know trying to study in Egypt at the
same time taking invitations going to
other places giving talks it was
impeding my process I actually learned
Arabic more in prison I actually started
to obtain more understanding of the
language the Quran you know the Books of
the elements and so on and so forth in
prison I ended you had access to all
that yeah absolutely I had maybe at one
time maybe over 92 books you know saying
maybe 80 90 percent of them in Arabic
and some in English I met a lot of
strong Brothers you know young
Palestinian brother named Mohammed was
the Imam in one spot he was younger than
me I benefited being around him another
brother named Hassan who was from
Bangladesh younger than me benefited
from him he was in half a half is in
Quran you know I've been in positions
where I've been the Imam and so on and
so forth so it's like what I thought I
had very little of became more of a
benefit in prison so then you start to
understand the wisdom behind where the
law decreed it wasn't so much about me
being this baby who just accepted Islam
it was that wherever I was exposed to
taught and learned of tawheed and
implementation of the understanding of
tohi it became a benefit for many people
in the prison system yeah so ultimately
this becomes the wisdom behind why
things happen so if I would win another
course
then my headline would probably be back
here stressed out lost weight just
looking meat because that is the sign of
someone who either Rejects
because if you don't accept you reject
the degree of Allah alhamdulillah never
placed in my heart anything that would
have made me feel like what he decreed
for me wasn't of my benefit
and then they're supposed to be relief
in that there's supposed to be some
Solace the relief is now sitting here
with my brother I mean the cutter this
but when you're in that situation and
you go back on that right
and this is supposed to help you get
through that absolutely right that's
part of it right because acceptance is
it takes the the the initial burden off
your shoulder yeah now moving forward
you can be clear yeah or what comes your
way you know the Hadith for the prophet
saw some said don't say if I did this or
that or the other you know say it's the
decree of Allah
yeah otherwise you drive yourself crazy
yeah that's what I'm saying you know
that's the beauty of us we live in our
hearts you know the True Believer lives
in his Hearts because this is the thing
that Allah taught us in the Quran yeah
the hearts not the intellect you know we
have AKA
but there's a place for that yeah but as
far as our ultimate living space is our
heart yeah you have to live here you
have to reside here in order to feel in
order to understand to comprehend
you know I'm saying and to act with
sound purpose it has to come from here
and then you were you were kind of
entrapped you were given some options
but those options were like okay it was
like if I go down that right that route
and try to fight for this Justice
I lose I get life in prison get life
imprisonment you know what I'm saying so
now this is where the awkward comes in
now we have to use our intellect yeah no
saying because what Allah says
do not kill yourselves right so that
would have been me killing myself
you know what I'm saying even though
alhamdulillah I'm innocent but the same
token I have you know my family has
rights you know I'm saying there's
people who Allah placed me in authority
over my wife my children you know saying
so and so forth people who looked at me
as the provider which I provide from
Allah's means right so with all of these
things in place you have to make a sound
decision
you have to weigh the benefit versus the
home right so the benefit is okay I take
the sentence there's daylight but the
same token I take the sentence I make
the most of the time
you know allow me to return in nine
years opposed to 14. you know it went
from 14 I got the two point reduction
dropped me down to 11 years and the fans
you do 87 or 85.5 however you want it so
that would have been nine years anyway
yeah then I get immediate release
I signed for a compassionate release I
got an immediate release
today is actually the day I was supposed
to get release
with no relief like with no compassion
and release No filing in court anything
today was my out date I was supposed to
come home today to get 11 months halfway
house was there something Trump was
mentioning all this was nothing to do
with nothing which I'm going to try
everything to do with me utilizing
whatever rights is given to me whatever
the rights there wasn't relinquished
during the course of my incarceration
utilizing those rights to file for
certain motions and cut little law I was
granted the compassion and release and I
was released immediately mashallah right
away alhamdulillah don't wait can't wait
I'm the alive and you're here with us
now alhamdulillah
he ends up leaving Romania according to
Dubai shortly after he says he makes up
Islam and now he comes back boom he's in
jail do you think now there's any
anything to that that because of his
conversion to Islam yeah they they
um I think it is playing to it at all I
think it may have been one factor of
numerous but to address that point
um
by raising another one I've seen there's
even a documentary coming out trying to
question Andrew's Faith which of course
is Haram but there are some kefirs who
are pushing that so they're going to do
what they're going to do that's
something that's they're working on I
actually spoke to them the other day the
idea that and they're claiming that you
spoke to them yeah I spoke to the uh
these documentary makers yeah just to
stand up for Andrew the idea that Andrew
reverted to Islam for clout first of all
the most Google man in the world doesn't
need more clout let's be real here and
the idea that it was some sort of
strategic decision if you're living in
Romania a strongly Orthodox country
is it going to be beneficial to convert
to Islam of course not and also let's be
honest there's a lot of ill will and a
lot of incorrect misperceptions about
Islam that you then take on once you
become Muslim I've told people I'm
Muslim and I've seen very strange
reactions and and I know that you know
people are saying certain things I don't
care you know I'm fine but for a lot of
people it does affect them negatively
and so the other the idea that becoming
Muslim is some sort of a strategic move
there's a lot of potential downsides
that come with it and one of them could
have been that Andrew wasn't viewed as
favorably in a heavily Orthodox country
most definitely I don't think it was
necessarily a driving reason behind is
you know is incarceration but I think it
may definitely have been a a factor
things
Sammy
[Music]
sir what do you think beautiful
beautiful so we transformed this from
people worshiping the creation to
worshiping the Creator Allah bless your
efforts Eddie
how are you doing brother
all right so as you can see we're
getting to work and we need your support
so go ahead and help us to get this
where it's Top Notch inshallah
[Music]
as Eddie was walking me through the
facility he was showing me that he has a
vision of having an Islamic school a
soup kitchen with the neighbors around
here benefit from the generosity of the
Muslims this has the potential to be a
beacon of light for the ummah join us in
this project inshallah so we can
establish the beautiful Dean Center
hmm